okay
so this right here why did I write the
long-term strategy today's message is
actually the long-term strategy why the
long-term strategy
if you've been following my content for
a while how many guys have read the book
your next five months raise your hand if
you've read the book your next five
months how many guys how many guys have
never read the book your next five
months you've never read it before you
may want to order the book and read it
for yourself the structure of
properties that we run it's all in the
book your next five moves this will be a
different kind of an angle to give you
the most important question everybody
has to ask today is who do you want to
be okay most important question for
people to ask today maybe more important
than two years ago than four years ago
then six years ago then ten years ago
it's today
for me it was simple born and raised in
Iran that's me on the left with my
sister to the right is me at 17 years
old I'm with my dad to the right of that
pictures when I joined the army I went
to the 101st Airborne Division aerosol I
had no clue what I wanted to do my life
and then I get out I start working with
Morgan Stanley Dean Witter
this picture is taken two weeks after 9
11.
while I'm working at Morgan Stanley Dean
with her
while Morgan Stanley lost 3 600
employees in their headquarters at World
Trade Center while A Man Named Dave
Kirby satisstan who was the general
manager branch manager of this place in
Glendale California and he said if you
guys left the industry today I would
fully understand it it's going to be
very very hard the next two years
think about a motivational speaker
giving you a message like that and it's
your boss
he sits us down vividly he says guys
if you chose to leave I fully get it the
next two year is going to be very hard
but I want to tell you something here
what's that if you do stick around and
you're in it after the two years
the kind of money some of you guys are
going to make none of us have ever made
before
so I sat there and I said okay I don't
know how this thing's going to be I
don't know how the Market's gonna be I
have no clue what the hell's about to
happen the meeting ends we all leave
and you know when you leave like imagine
Albert holds a meeting and then you
leave and you're sitting there talking
to yourself you're having lunch with
your guys
shall we leave
I go to the corner it's 10 of us we're
sitting there talking
I'm like so what are you going to be
doing this guy named Shaq
he was Asian but his name was Shaq which
made no sense because it was 5'4 but his
name was Shaq
so
Shack's like guys hey let me tell you
what I'm going to be doing what are you
going to be doing I'm going to go get a
job at the bank because I'm going to be
the broker at the bank and guess what
they're going to do at the bank what's
that dude all you do is nothing you just
go through their database and you just
sell the existing customers no more cold
calling no more prospecting no more this
no more debt no more this you're never
going to do that or what you're going to
make 170 250 eventually three four
hundred thousand it's the best job in
the world that's what I'm going to be
doing I'm sitting on like huh see what
the next guy's going to say next guy
says man I got to tell you man I'm going
to go into a completely different
industry okay what's the next guy going
to say that everybody's talking from a
place of leaving
one guy comes out and says hey Pat
all these guys whatever they said you
don't ever want to go to the bank why is
that because when you have a job that's
that's easy and you all of a sudden get
too sloppy they fire you bring somebody
else because everybody wants that job
you don't ever want to work at the bank
because they'll always fire that person
because it's an easy job you're an order
taker never take that job don't fall for
it I'm like great counsel then this guy
said this that guy said this this guy
said this I said look
I'm gonna stick around
and by the way while this whole thing is
going on I'm going through a bad breakup
the Army's asking me to come back to
wipe out my forty nine thousand dollars
of debt if I go back into the army
nothing's going my way in this picture
don't let the smile fool you nothing's
going good in my my way right now okay
the girl in the right I don't know if
you see that girl to the right to the
right of the light do you see the light
in 1997 she graduated high school she
got a 1560 on her sat out of 1600.
she went to UC Berkeley got a four-year
degree in two and a half years
she also left she went and became a
scientist she makes two three hundred
thousand dollars a year as a scientist
so I'm sitting there saying Pat what the
hell are you going to be doing
sat there I said you know what here's
what I've learned every book I read said
go to a place
or a market or an industry where there's
a lot of problems
be the solution be the voice be poised
be calm bring the energy to the place
you'll create a ton of wealth don't go
to the place where there's no problems
go to the place where there is problems
and become the solution
I'm like okay all these books are saying
the same thing why the hell would I
leave the industry because no industry
has more problems than the financial
industry right after 2001 911. like you
know what I'm sticking around so I stick
around
I stick around I get my whole licenses
everything I double down I get my
insurance license
I go to trans
world I stay with them for seven and a
half years do incredibly well for myself
October of all night we start our own
insurance company and we grow the
insurance company from 66 agents we've
licensed now 35 000 agents we have 20
000 active agents few hundred offices
Nationwide
and we stay focused part-time I'm
creating content 2012 2013 I do my first
video I did one video a week two minutes
with Pat
and I said I'm gonna do a hundred videos
for two years
if the audience doesn't like the way I
give my message I will shut it down I'll
never create content again but I'm going
to do one video a week on a phone
two minutes with Pat like this and I'll
try it once a week
we did a hundred videos every single
video was over two minutes typically 12
15 minutes the only video that was ever
two minutes was the last video the
biggest complaint I got is Pat you can't
say too many sweatpad you're lying to
all of us you got to say 10 minutes with
that 15 minutes with that none of them
are two minutes
two years later we changed our strategy
for content
next thing you know the content goes on
what it's doing then we get a hundred
thousand Subs half a million Subs a
million subs today we got I don't know
four and a half five million Subs we got
like 10 YouTube channels a few hundred
thousand few Channels with few hundred
thousand Subs Russian language Spanish
language we're launching Arabic Mandarin
a whole different thing that we're doing
with that business that grew 90 days ago
the insurance company we partner with a
new company called IMG money came from
uh Silver Lake money
we sold a business for a very very very
nice
multi-multi nine-figure type of
evaluation and we had a nice
83 percent give or take equity in the
company
why am I sharing the story with you
when I'm here I'm broke
this was my vision I wanted to one day
have this
I told my family I told myself when I
was 23 24 years old
relationship didn't work out I said
listen long term Pat not short term long
term what life do you want
I sat there I said long term
these Americans eventually if you have
kids these Americans like to do these uh
what do you do when the kids get
together and they spend the night at
someone's house what do they call that
stuff
what do you call it
I don't like sleepovers
I'm from Iran guys we don't do
sleepovers but if you are gonna do
sleepovers you're going to do it at our
house with 40 cameras around it's the
only place you're doing a sleepover at
well now my kids are not doing a
sleepover at your place you can come to
my place okay
then I said one day when I'm a
grandfather
and we have our kids that marry other
people
their kids our grandkids are gonna
decide which grandpa's house and
Grandma's house they want to go for
Christmas and Thanksgiving
we have to offer the best place
what do you mean we got out for the best
place I want the in-laws to stay I want
their kids to stay bring your grandkids
if it's 40 I'm going to get a house big
enough for 40 50 people stay in one
place
why you want to do that by the way I'm
saying this at 24 years old I'm only 43
right now I'm thinking at 65 70 years
old whose house Jennifer and I the other
day are looking at a house we want to
buy in uh babe are you in the audience
are you in the back I don't know where
she's at maybe she's going to bed oh
okay we're looking at a house the other
day in Greenwich do you guys know where
Greenwich is at you know on the
Connecticut area the house we're looking
at is 12 acres it's 20 something 25 000
square foot house 40 million dollar
house and we want to buy this place
because we want to have a place where
the family can go and I'm going to
create the podcast set where we do
podcasts from their kids play there
somewhere you stay there 60 days 90 days
we do business back and forth we open up
a business office or I can do business
from there while we're staying at our
Greenwich house guys I've been thinking
about this life
20 years
20 years
and the reason why I'm sharing this with
you at this time
because so many people are currently
worried about short-term issues
interest rates fed Russia Ukraine all of
this mess it's true it is a very very
scary time but if you're thinking long
term it's not a scary time it's a
regular Tuesday when you're thinking
long term does that make sense to
everybody so now this is what I'm saying
to you long term what life do you want
to have
we got four kids now
Brooklyn's at the top
she is extremely smart you know how I
know that
her first words were Daddy
and she loves me the most brilliant kid
this kid knows what she's doing
we got Senna that's right next to mommy
she has no clue who I am she sees me as
the person that just makes the money of
course she loves me but she's in love
with Mommy right
Fireball
Dylan is the one in the pink Patrick is
one in a blue
four days ago I'm at the house I'm like
guys you know one of you guys going to
be a president one day
and they're like Dylan's like it's not
going to be me I said I didn't say it's
going to be you
I said one of you it could be Brooklyn
it could be Santa it could be Tico it
could be you but one of you is going to
be a president one day
by the way what's the chances of one of
my kids being a president one day you
know what the chances point zero zero
zero one if you actually do the
percentage how slim is it it's a very
small number so I tell them that
and I notice he's like it's not going to
be me it's going to be one of them three
I'm like okay let's see if he's gonna
bite three minutes later you know what
question he asked me
he says um
hey Daddy I got a question for you
what's that
how old do you have to be to be a
president
it's a buying question that's all I want
I said 35 you got a long ways to go
we're not we're going to talk about it
later on but one of you guys will be
president one day what's the point here
I have no idea if any of this stuff's
going to become a reality or not none of
this stuff I have no idea but I'm
casting a vision and I'm thinking long
term when you have a vision long term
that you're excited about current issues
don't stress you out
they don't every one of your competitors
many of them that are not going to make
it the next two years I can guarantee
you right now ninety percent of them all
they're thinking about is today
that's all I'm going to tell you I
guarantee you because I had a lot of
guys I went up against in the last 20
something years that were bigger than me
smarter than me better degrees better
markets better background better
accolades better speakers better
everything they look better they look
like somebody that would be a silver
insurance company do I look like a CEO
of an insurance company I look like a
bodyguard from the Middle East I don't
look like a Sylvan Insurance Company
the typical insurance agent was a 56
year old white male I asked the guy said
what percentage of insurance agents are
from Iran because like what are you
talking about
I said out of all these agents we have
in America what percentage are Iranian I
said no listen Pat you guys are in the
other section there's white then it's
Asian then it's Hispanic then it's black
then it's this then it's that you're in
the other section less than one percent
I'm not supposed to be here that's what
I'm trying to tell you okay but again
long term is the way to think today in
this economy
[Music]